hello everyone
welcome to
rational science
the only site on the internet that does
physics everybody else does
mathematical descriptions
and physics is about
explanations it's about explaining
mechanisms especially those invisible
mechanisms that we have yet to identify
okay
but
first we are going to start with
uh subject matter which i love which is
the subject matter known as extinction
extinction of man
are we gonna become
extinct are we gonna end up extinct
as a species right
and i'm saying not only that we will but
very soon indeed
anyways uh questions that people ask and
and subject matter related to extinction
uh
headlines in the news etc that's what i
cover in the first uh half of the
lecture
okay so we're going to start with uh
you've heard of omicron you've heard of
the
covid latest covid
uh strain strand variant
well um you know the the other
uh
strains uh like the alpha beta delta all
those are gone those are in the past
now we have the omicron okay
and uh supposedly everybody's guarding
against them for the winter okay in the
northern hemisphere especially
and here what you find it says vaccines
against omnicron the bottom line this
comes from the top
people in the united states right the
omicron variant compromises
the effects of two dose mrna
vaccine-induced antibodies and reduces
all overall vaccine protection but
considerable protection against severe
disease is maintained
in other words the um
the vaccine they gave you if if you got
the vaccine
allegedly covers you even for the
omnicron right
but they suggest that you get a third
doses the booster
okay so uh they say our boosted uh
vaccine regimens uh work against omicron
no need for a variant specific booster
at this time not yet they haven't
invented the the the one that uh
attacks the omicron right
and um
and here you have uh
one uh
situation that i looked up this week
and it's all the enemies of the united
states what do they have to say
about um omicron okay and these are the
main enemies right
so uh what do they say well uh here here
they are individually okay here we have
especially uh iran russia
uh north korea and cuba right and this
is the russians let me get this gun out
of here
here we have the russians and they say
they have detected omicron variant in 16
people uh who came from south africa
okay and the moscow times right says
that the sputnik 5 robust against
omicron
it claims that the sputnik 5 is robust
against the omicron
and so they say
again no need to take a booster of a new
kind of vaccine because the one they
have already takes care of that problem
right the omicron variant
and here you have the cubans and they
have a similar situation they found uh
first case a few days ago and then uh
more recently a few days later in fact a
couple days ago
um
they detected four more cases of the
omicron in cuba right
and uh says that cuba aspires to have a
vaccine ready
against the omicron variant
uh so we get a little bit of a
contradiction we have one country a
couple countries russia and the united
states they say no need to invent a new
vaccine the old vaccine works against
omnichrome and here the cubans are
trying to develop a new vaccine
or a vaccine right that attacks the
omicron variant
isn't that a little suspicious
you know i mean uh
haven't though cubans found out that uh
you know the
the
old vaccine works against the omicron
are they the only ones who don't know
about it
and here you have iran another country
that
uh you could say is an enemy of the
united states says iran minister says
new corona virus strain omicron could
spread
iran health red minister has warned
about the possibility okay not the
certainty but possibility of the new
coronavirus variant omicron spreading in
the country but did not announce any
travel bans
okay so they're not uh raising any flags
yet they're just saying well you know
there's this new variant and we're we're
aware of it we're on the lookout but
we're not going to stop the country okay
and it says looms
but iran has no means of detecting it
well i guess if the old vaccine
works on omicron
why do you need to even detect it
right
i mean you would think that if if you
get the like i did the the two shots
right
hopefully i'm protected against the
amicron as well because
they say that the vaccine they gave me
works against the the omicron variant as
well
okay so i don't know
we're looking at some
seems like some contradictions out there
that's what it seems like to me okay
okay and uh what about north korea well
here we have them and they say uh you
know they weren't against the omnicron
variant right but
they haven't uh found any cases
yet in north korea
and here they're raising flags all over
the place here in germany at least it's
unbelievable they've already
put all these rules that you need to
have a third shot and that um
if you don't have the two shots they're
gonna require a coveted test
like a daily one like if you're stopped
on the street by the gestapo
you know and so uh
here's a big deal and apparently in
other countries they had what one or two
cases 16 cases
are we going to stop the world because
we had one or two or three or four cases
and so you know the question is whether
this is real or not anymore
you know for me um it's starting to
become like uh
an excuse
to because the politicians can't fix the
economy they said well we can't fix it
because of the omicron
and
the reason we had to shut down all the
hotels all the restaurants
all the barber shops
uh all the
nightclubs is because this bug is out
there
and turns out you know it kills
maybe or it hasn't killed anyone
apparently yet uh but there's been like
a few cases a handful of cases
maybe one twenty
something like that
so the question is uh should we stop the
world because there's this bug out there
and and the reason i'm asking that also
is because there's another issue and
that's that
um
it's winter season
and
lots of people go out there and get
their flu shots remember the flu this
was a bug that
we we paid attention to so for so many
years
and now nobody even mentions the flu
isn't anybody getting sick because of
the regular coals or flues
this is this
this is the season you know
and so
you know it's like we forget about the
flu or maybe we're mistaking this
cobit thing for the flu and vice versa
you know i mean
the question is
you know what happened to the flu
it has the covet displaced the flu
is that's what's happened one bug
replaced the other like you know the
killer bees replacing the bumble bee or
something like that
i don't know
it does uh make you stop and think uh
what's going on right so i can't blame
the uh people who are
conspiracists as they're known
uh
i sympathize with them here you know
because uh it's not very clear what's
going on okay
at least to me
okay uh
so here we go with uh this thought he
says uh we were talking about koben and
uh he said that
uh
kobet is a fake just like uh hiv aids
was a fake and he says well you know you
had hardcore drugs and malnutrition
those were confused or those created the
situation where people got sick
and i guess he's saying that that
somehow um
had something to do with the fact that
hiv aids spread right
okay um
he said also that there's a drug that
was applied to or that you know people
got
to see if they could cure be cured of
aids and i guess it just made them worse
or killed them or whatever
uh yeah these are theories and again uh
you know
different people have different theories
out there about
all these diseases not only coped but
aids and so on these
modern day diseases in the case of aids
as far as i'm concerned the hiv
they got it from the jungle somewhere i
guess someone slept with a gorilla
or something out there and brought it
into civilization
the question
now comes with this other bug the copid
where did that one come from i mean
allegedly it started in china it started
in a city right
so we're not talking about you know
someone going into the jungle
a uh an unexplored area
and some somehow came in contact with a
new disease
here we're talking about a city wuhan
right
and
that bug
was just all of a sudden just popped
into existence out of nowhere
you know it's kind of weird uh
you would think that uh
if we come across a disease
it would be something that no one has
encountered before because it's it's
isolated from humans from from the
majority from the human population
but you know people have been living in
wuhan for a long time now and we just
caught it now it just popped into
existence out of nowhere
you know things that make you stop and
think uh what's going on again you know
we got to try to reason this out because
uh the information that's out there is a
little confusing and contradictory okay
and so you know it's up to you to
uh imagine what's really going on
okay um
here we have another issue
if i can get it there um we talked about
brain sizes and intelligence the if
there's a correlation
and there was an article that says uh
rocket scientists and brain surgeons are
not necessarily smarter than the rest of
us study fines okay so they did a test
on uh several
people
several thousands of people of britain's
right they compared them against with
two uh 329
aerospace engineers 72 neuro surgeons
and they said there's no significant
difference in the
uh general population and these guys as
far as you know how smart they are
the conclusion i said there was no
significant difference in how aerospace
engineers scored versus the general uk
population
neurosurgeons only showed faster problem
solving and slower memory recall
so uh
you know we always talk about the rocket
scientists um
you know maybe not
maybe these guys are no different than
you
okay
again
opinion maybe in the end but here
there's a study right that says there is
no difference in uh if we're going to
talk about intelligence
like if that test measures intelligence
which is a separate issue well then
there is no significant difference in
the intelligence or smartness of
you know these so-called rocket
scientists neurosurgeons
and the average population okay in other
words
those rocket sciences they're human
okay so here we have uh another issue
with brain and intelligence follows us
dissect the conflict on brains
and intelligence if you can
intelligence is such an abstraction that
maybe humanity never gets to understand
how it physically works on a micro level
within its time on earth before
extinction
and another fellow
brings up a parallel issue okay and
let's just go through it so that you see
how it's related to this okay it says by
what
uh happens when we die i am in fact
referring to what happens when you or i
die personally i thought originally his
question had to do with the extinction
of man and not with um
personal death okay
well nothing happens that's it that's
what i answered he said sounds like an
irrational answer you're just
conjuring an image of a black background
i believe that one can only be conscious
therefore when we die we either relive
life from the beginning
okay
i don't know about that without memory
or our conscious as something else okay
so what we come back from the dead or
there's a soul that survives is that
what we're saying here
of course i have trouble defining what
consciousness is i would say that it is
just sensing
okay so we have uh these questions uh
what are we talking about we're talking
about um
mind spirit soul
all these ques all these words that we
use to define
consciousness or thinking or whatever
you want to call it we've got
all these variants of of what
thinking is
and people have for
hundreds of years believe that
there's this thing called spirit soul
mind consciousness that somehow is
separate from the body
it's been the discussed ad nauseam
throughout the ages
is there such a thing is there such a
standalone object
thing
known as consciousness
and all i can give you is my
humble
version and that's that consciousness is
is a verb there's no such thing as
consciousness
and people who confuse consciousness for
this spirit this ghost
that
leaves the body some people say that you
weigh more with a ghost in
than
when the ghost leaves you they say now
you weigh less
even assuming that were the case are we
saying that that ghost
uh not only has shape but has
weight mass
what's it made out of uh atoms
i mean these people who are are the dark
ages that's what it is okay
so let's find out let's uh
let's go into this thingy uh we call
mind thought
uh spirit whatever word you want to put
in there okay
and i start with this this is what you
this is what you're seeing here is um
areas of the brain okay
and uh
in this case it's got to do with love
which is one of the ones that has been
studied and these are neurons and these
are different parts of the brain that
they found
are activated when a person
has this thingy we call love okay this
attraction and there are different kinds
of love there's maternal love there's a
sexual love etc but uh this just
to show you how the brain works in other
words these things apparently are
turning on
and they were able to map the brain to
some degree and say look these are the
regions that of the brain that turn on
and off when someone
experiences this thingy we call love
okay
and
uh here's uh
uh
what happens with these neurons let me
show you this the uh especially the
synapse okay and it's uh you have all
these um
neurons uh their
cells essentially
and there are
gaps between them that we can't see
anything in there
and the question and they still
communicate
through that
gap through that
separation there
and
you know assuming it's some electrical
signal or maybe magnetic signal
of course we would not see it if
especially if it's magnetic right there
would be nothing near for us to see
uh the question is whether
are we going to
simulate this or mimic it you know with
the
proposal by quantum mechanics which are
little electrons that flow across that
gap
or you could say it's magnetism whatever
they want to put in there
or are we going to simulate it with the
rope model where you have something
physical that you can't see or touch
okay so the question is what's in that
region okay between the the uh neurons
and i think this gives us an idea of
how the brain works
you know when uh when they pinch your
toe with a little needle
okay you feel it immediately
so where do you feel it
and you say well i felt it in my toe
because that's where they pinched me
but see when you see a or when you find
a quadriplegic person who
can't you know has his neck anything
below the neck is paralyzed he can't
feel anything here can't move anything
you can pinch his toe
and he doesn't feel it
and you say well i thought it was
locally i thought you felt it there but
here you pinch this guy he doesn't feel
it
not only he cannot move anything but he
cannot feel it
meaning that what has been severed is
the connection between that little
area of his toe
and his brain
okay so something there was cut off
usually something in the back of the
neck or depending on the injury right
and so
you know he doesn't feel it and he
doesn't feel it because
his head somehow is disconnected
internally from that region
of the toe
okay and so this gives us an idea that
you know we're all connected all the way
from the head to the toe if you cut off
something which is internal uh
that connects those things
you know physical connection
well then now you can't feel the toe
and and yet all that all those nerves
are connected
you know when you do feel the pinch all
those are connected
by uh neurons that are separated from
each other by these synapses
and so the question is
is there a disconnect between
two cells two neurons
or are they connected physically but we
can't see what connects them
okay
is there maybe magnetism flowing in that
region is it uh some kind of chemical
or is it electricity right
and
that's uh gives us an idea of maybe how
the brain works i'm saying a lot of this
is electro
magnetic
and when we look at electromagnetic
we're talking we're going to look at uh
what we're seeing today and that's that
we're looking at torsion
in situ torsion you know like when a
rope turns
in in situ right
nothing's really moving in in the
direction in the opposite directions
here of the rope now it's twirling in
place and the ends you know by twirling
the end
you know that's causing already
a thump
a
some kind of uh
influence
over the atom that's at the other end
and when you look at it from that point
of view you know nothing needs to travel
at the speed of light
from your toe to your head
there is no
you know little electron ball that goes
from your toe to your head
it's a torsion that's in situ
and the only reason you know
quadriplegic can't feel it is because
that physical connection is severed
and you can also look at it as a serial
assuming it's uh we're talking about
electricity
you know again it's merged cells
merge
shells or membranes
that twirl in place and there's a
connection all the way from your toe all
the way to your head
and if you cut that
physical connection
if now they're separated right adam from
atom or molecule from molecule
uh
cell from cell right
now you get a gap there now there is no
continuity
okay so uh
keep that in mind that's what
i think electricity is we're going to
look at that a little bit
today okay uh
we're gonna look at now the uh
what is it governments
file says anyone who thinks that elites
aren't in control should try and take
control
of any of the world's natural resources
and see what happens or try to start
your own utility company or claim
ownership for air rights around some
airports build your own dam and we are
now have always been forever will be
slaves to the elite
okay
uh
thinking otherwise a clear sign of one's
delusion okay
another fellow
says almost the opposite he says uh not
that he's wrong but he says we should
have
authoritarianism
you know he says
if the soviet union had won the cold war
we might not have been in a
in a harboring extinction crisis now the
state would have controlled the means of
production food and import machines
would have been produced for the people
and shitty technology would have been
made them do it themselves what i mean
is that the economy would not
progressively become based on
superfluous things such as distraction
knowledge and services
and people could fall back on the state
when the economy collapses
an authoritarian state might also give
people great purposes perhaps we could
uh far out from the earth and colonize
the solar system
uh
yeah i don't think so you know uh at
least i can only give you my
uh five cents worth on that i'm saying
first of all let's make sure we we
cannot conquer the solar system okay
um
we're never going to colonize it
terraform it or anything like that like
carl sagan suggested once
it's never going to happen
we might the best we can probably
achieve which i doubt anyways but it
could happen
because i think we have the technology
to do so is you know we could visit mars
we could send a group
of
astronauts all the way to mars
and i think we have the technology to
or close to it to achieve that goal
but even you know like colonizing mars
like putting something out up there and
saying okay we're going to live there no
never going to happen obviously not
same for the moon we might visit the
moon but are we going to put some
stations on the moon and live on the
moon
absolutely not never going to happen
and
one of the things that you have to think
about is that even if we were to achieve
that even if we were to put a colony on
the moon or on mars and like the guy in
the movie you know
plant potatoes out there
um
you know so what uh what have we
achieved in other words are we going to
expand throughout the solar system
and let's even concede that okay so we
colonize every everything up to pluto
that is inhabitable right
then what
where do we go from there are we going
to make it to the nearest star
uh 4.3
million uh light years away
uh i'm sorry 4.3 light years away uh you
know you're talking about a long
distance there and and the question is
are we ever going to go to the nearest
star
and the answer is obviously not okay
it's never going to happen so even if we
were to colonize the entire solar system
so what the earth is probably the
biggest planet
that is inhabitable
uh
you know in fact i think it is
and venus is close by there but
even if we terraform those are we going
to populate in other words double our
population by going to these other
stones
instead of what 8 billion or 9 billion
people we're going to be 18 billion
because we're spread out throughout the
solar system 18 billion or more right
no it's never going to happen partly
because you know we've already exhausted
our genetic diversity
here on earth that's one issue the other
one is that you know we stop having
children so there's no incentive no
pressure
to leave the earth i mean if we were
overflowing and people were falling off
the earth because the earth is so
populated yeah but you know we're so far
away the earth is still a
an empty land
there's a lot of
places we could inhabit right now in
russia russia is an empty country
argentina
empty country
all these are empty countries
and people don't understand that they
say oh it's over the world is
overpopulated no no
at least as far as
space is concerned we got a lot of space
out there i don't know if we have enough
resources for people that's
that's a separate issue i'm saying that
we have space
space is not
uh a scarce resource as of today okay we
could probably fit a trillion people on
the earth i'm talking only about space
not talking about resources okay
space wise we can fit a lot more people
than we have today okay so space we have
but we're not filling that space because
we don't have children we're not having
children anymore okay women stopped
having children and uh so yes that's
gonna come to a stop
and so do we need to have is there any
pressure for us to go to mars
or to venus or whatever
absolutely not we're not going to go out
there you know right now all those are
uh
projects
uh lab projects to say hey be nice to
see if we can develop the technology and
the know-how
how to get there
yeah that's great
uh don't tell me we're gonna live there
absolutely not there's
i gotta get that off your head see i
used to believe all that stuff once
myself i thought you know we were gonna
go out into space and other planets
conquer the sol the not only the solar
system but other star systems and move
on to the galaxy
no way no way it's gonna ever happen
okay that's my five cents worth i'm not
okay here we go first it says the reason
free market has worked so well is
because its foundation
is self-interest now that's a little
more rational than the other two fellows
okay
and economy is literally all of us rich
and poor taking care of our
self-interest
yeah and that's uh
the adam smith uh
philosophy you know
everybody taking care of themselves
moves
progress forward
uh yeah that's uh the way it all works
so
you know people have different ideas
about
what government should be some people
believe like the southern fell that
should be authoritarian somehow that you
need to put some kind of order and it's
got to come from above because if you
let the masses
uh rule or whatever it's not gonna
happen you gotta impose
order on the people below put impose the
law so to speak
other people say oh i'm being crushed by
these laws i don't want them anymore who
are you to tell me what to do and so we
have all these difference of opinions
but the
important one at least as related to
economics is you know self-interest
absolutely
okay um
fella says your conception of human
evolution
uh as devolution uh reminds me much of
the creationist view of the evolution
do you align yourself with the
creationist view of evolution
accuses me of being a creationist i
can't believe this
what about religious views on the end of
the world namely the events of
revelation
now my theory has absolutely nothing to
do with the bible i mean i didn't even
get the idea from the bible at all
uh i got in fact from relativity
because you have all these
mathematicians and they're saying we're
all going to go
into outer space we're going to conquer
the solar system the stars the galaxy
and maybe other galaxies that's the idea
because they just
imagine this thing
evolving forward forever and ever and
they say oh there's so many things we're
going to invent in the future
and invention is is done with
there are no more inventions we've
invented everything we needed to invent
they have any relevance okay
they changed the color of the car well
you can say that's an invention yeah
like one invention out there that came
out a couple years ago was beer a beer
that
was it um
something about the beer i can't
remember now but it was a special type
of beer yeah beer is beer is beer and
you can
change something about that beer
and they call it an invention you know
no because the guy who drinks beer is
going to drink that beer or another beer
it doesn't matter
and it's the same if you change a blue
car for a red car
is that an invention well yeah i guess
you could say that that cosmetic change
you can patent it you know copyrighted
or whatever
yeah right now we only make cosmetic
changes out there manufacturing is dead
uh manufacturing is dying before our
very eyes okay it's becoming a smaller
percentage of gdp and of labor
we're replacing humans with machines to
do a lot of that work
and all humans are going into services
so uh
you know
there's gonna be no more inventions so
if you don't hold your breath this
notion that some people have out there
uh that there's gonna be this
technological singularity where
things take off
exponentially because suddenly you have
these robots doing the inventions for us
and they're going to come up with so
many things we cannot even imagine
and yeah
it's like putting it off like saying i
can't tell you what because you know i'm
not one of those robots that's going to
be inventing all this stuff
and so they can just imagine that
this is going to take off
and no manufacturing is on its way down
not on its way up there's going to be no
technological singularity we're at the
end of the line
and not only are we not producing
people
and children babies
but we're not producing technology
either manufacturing that's dead as well
so
again uh my five cents worth on that
uh says what you're saying uh what
you're arguing for is oddly enough a
catastrophe which is not as likely to
occur as a broad systemic shift i
propose instead that civilization will
slowly wither on the vine
okay slowly he says it's going to be a
slow gradual process okay as it adjusted
the decline of fossil fuel resources and
deals with crushing birth rates
compounded by a gigantic aging
population and this genetic uh incentive
structure humanity may or may not go
extinct because of in this gradual
process there will be some organized
societies that will attempt to adapt
so he's saying that we can overcome
extinction because it's a slow process
it gives us time to think
and to fix the problem whatever the
problem is
and someone will survive and restart the
race all over again that's that's more
or less what he's saying here okay
of course extinction is ultimately about
food
okay how that came in there i have no
idea because he wasn't talking about
food so far so if there's still food out
there it doesn't really matter whether
civilization collapses or not there will
be those who continue
so he's running around in circles he's
saying yeah it's about food extinction
but we don't have to worry because
there's always going to be some food out
there and as long as there's some food
out there someone will survive
and they'll restart the race
this is a notion this is what he's
thinking here i think that's what will
happen to man a smaller dinkier
civilization that will never rise back
to its former glory
uh so what i guess what he's saying is
what we're
we're gonna be 10 people on the earth
and we're going to have this food and
it's just not going to rise to the
uh 8 billion people we have today is
that what we're saying here
uh what can i say
let's go with another one because uh
this file says and this is gonna put it
in the right context okay uh how long
will it take for mankind to fill that to
fall are we talking about years or
decades will mankind actually go extinct
and so my answer is mankind will
go extinct
mankind has no possibility whatsoever
of overcoming extinction okay that's
what i'm going to argue okay i'm saying
we have no way of fixing this problem no
matter what we do no matter how much
intelligence we have no it doesn't
matter how much technology we have it
doesn't matter that we can foresee
events and react to them none of that
has any bearing on the cause of
extinction that's why i constantly
remind people that they should do
extinction 101 before they do extinction
102. everybody's an expert on 102 which
is human extinction and i have yet to
find experts on extinction
specifically mass extinction
how did the dinosaurs die if you cannot
tell me that don't talk to me about
humans
you know nothing about extinction and
you want to talk about human extinction
please tell me how the animals in the
past died and that's
that's what science is about that's what
the
extinction of man is about it's not
about the future it's about the past
it has to do with
the mechanism of extinction how did the
animals in the past die how did they
become extinct once we figure that out
we have to apply that mechanism to man
and see if he can overcome it
and yeah the only one that we cannot
overcome is food
okay we cannot overcome food because our
our whole economy
is um
is a um
inverted pyramid scheme
we're always expecting
you know to be more people in the future
so that we sell more products and that
keeps our economy going
but that was good primarily for the
manufacturing age which died some 50
years ago now
and
it's still applicable to the service age
you know if you have more people out
there you can provide them with more
services but services is a little easier
to provide you know like a song
you can provide to millions and it's
just one song one singer
that's different in manufacturing if you
need to provide a million television
sets
you need to produce a million television
sets for a million people
so services
like you know intangibles those are a
lot easier to to spread around okay than
manufacturing
manufacturing you know goods
tangible goods
uh
you know you require one per person
whereas the other one uh you can have
one
uh and one thingy whatever it is one
concept
and you can spread it out to eight
billion people
without any problem a song uh
uh
or whatever it is you know a
specification
how to do something knowledge all that
stuff you know you can spread very
easily
uh you don't have to produce it
physically that's the difference
anyways uh if i asked uh how soon are we
or how close are we to extinction and
i've got this graph there that more or
less puts it in the right perspective
and again i want to
emphasize that this gives me an idea of
when it's going to happen okay and for
what 300 200 000 years we were
hunter-gatherers hunters primarily i'd
say
maybe 10 000 years we were farmers maybe
200 300 years we were into industry we
created the industrial revolutions maybe
in the late 18th century somewhere
around there
and about
50 years ago now we went into services
and perhaps the last 10 years or so we
went into new kinds of services we went
into internet services okay
and uh so we're not doing any hands-on
services like i discussed the other day
where we have restaurants and hotels
that require maids you know and uh
restaurants require
cooks and busboys and servers and so on
and all those jobs are now being killed
and what are we replacing them with well
people are moving into internet they're
doing a lot of internet stuff which is
you know just
some concept out there again that you
can spread to millions through the
internet
some hit it big and they say oh i got i
i'm making a lot of money with this
great one guy does it one
guy does hit the jackpot but the
majority of people you know they're
going to get crumbs out there and
a lot of people just can't enter that
business they're just going to be
customers not providers
and so we're moving people out of the
hands-on services now into these these
abstract services which are you know the
uh
internet services
and
other people are unemployed they receive
money from the government
uh others you know maybe sell drugs on
the streets or live with their parents
uh you know you've got all sorts of
people out there
and so the question is you know we're
abandoning now
the jobs that this covet thing is
pushing people out of the hands-on jobs
right
and going into these abstract internet
jobs services
you know programming and so on that's
that's big still today
and can we live on uh
entertainment alone
on leisure
so that's food for thought for you can
we live can man live on leisure alone
someone might even say yes out there
okay i'm gonna say no okay
okay final issue says did you go to a
rational doctor for your problems or did
you go to a mainstream doctor who relies
on past experiments measurements
accurate predictions and all the
mainstream science you consider
nonsense
oh my god
poor fellow you know he the problem here
is he doesn't understand the difference
between science and technology
all that he mentioned here has to do
with technology
when you go to uh when you go to a
doctor and he cures you he's not doing
science okay it's not called science
okay it's that's mathematics
okay
uh they call it science
uh when you do an experiment and when
you cure someone of something because
you gave him a drug you gave him a
massage uh
[Music]
you know you
maybe fix his leg
somehow
oh that's technology that's not science
science has nothing to do with someone
touching you
or giving you a drug or anything like
that science is that doctor
who's in the one corner maybe at his
office his desk and he says now let's
see what causes cancer
that's the scientist
okay now the guy that cures you of
cancer
he's not a scientist
okay
uh that's mathematics notion of science
so uh yeah so this fellow doesn't
understand the difference between
science and
technology
and this technology thingy
is what the mathematicians
consider science in fact uh you know the
uh nobel prize
is given not only to people who come up
with theories
you know
in fact most of them are not given to
people who come up with theories a lot
of them are given to people who invent
something
you know i mean uh marconi for example
he got it for supposedly inventing the
telegraph right
or having to do with the invention of
the telegraph what's that got to do with
science
i mean is this uh
is this a
metal that they give for science or for
technology
what are they giving that metal for
and so it's a mixture why because the
mathematicians consider
lab experiments hands-on experiments and
all these uh
you know inventions
they considered it
as part of science
okay
no it's not we separate science
from technology science is explanations
you have to explain something
and when i went to the doctor you know
uh we had a little bit of both we had a
little bit of science a little bit of
technology but this value mentions has
to do with technology
the part that dealt with science is when
the doctor gave me
her opinion
her theory of what could be wrong
so it could be this could be that
and
you know these are theories that uh
that they don't know for sure it could
be this or it could be that right
uh so
again it's what you believe in
uh
they might say well you know i think you
have this
and you should take this medicine
okay and maybe you take it with a grain
of sand uh salt you might say well
you know when you go home you say well
should i do that should i really take
that that
remedy that drug
and you might decide not to because you
you're not confident that your doctor
really hit it on the nose okay
doctor says i know why you have a
headache uh you have it because you've
been drinking too much beer take an
aspirin
and maybe you think you have a headache
because you know someone hits you over
the head
and then all you need is a pack of ice
so so we have a differences of
technology to address the problem which
has nothing to do with science which was
the
cause the the theory of why you have
some some kind of ailment okay
so yeah we have to distinguish science
from technology
okay let's move on to the subject matter
of today what are we going to talk about
today we're going to talk about voltage
what the hell is voltage
well the other day we talked a little
bit about electricity and before that
we've been talking about
mass and
uh energy especially
another form of mass mass is another
form of energy right and there were some
issues that were brought up
and so we need to address those before
as an introduction to the subject matter
of today okay okay so one thought says
this is what most people use the term
physics
for
alpha fina gives a
link says alpha phoenix did what most
people call physics to verify derek
muller's claim because i dealt with
derek muller's notion of what
electricity is okay flow of particles he
says not really it's uh it's in situ
uh something happens there the the
electrons move back and forth you know
from atom to atom they don't go all the
way to the terminal okay
what do you call it technology
mathematics
okay
yeah we got a problem because these
people don't understand what physics is
about they don't understand what science
is about that's the issue and when you
go to these this alpha phoenix guy
uh
you know you find that what do you find
you find the same exact thing as what
derek muller had
in other words
he hasn't changed anything he hasn't
said anything different
than derek muller
and and so
he says oh he
the fact that he challenged derek miller
now they said the same thing they used
the same electricity they said that
there's an electron bead
okay that moves from one atom to the
next to the neighbor
okay because this is what they learned
at the monastery okay they learned that
electricity is the flow of electrons
whether they flow all the way around
whether they flow only to the next atom
then come back like in
alternate current
uh it's the flow of electron beads from
one atom to another the conduction band
right that's what's known as electricity
in uh just about everywhere the electric
universe believes in that the uh john
chappelle uh society uh people who
believe in particles and ether and stuff
like that
you have the quantum mechanics string
theorist
general relativity they all
even the uh classical people people who
believe in classical mechanics
everybody
essentially believes in that
that the electricity is the flow of
electron beads and
and the the in order to come up with
that notion
they have to use the quantum atom
and a quantum atom is the planetary atom
so that's why they have this little b
that's going around right the nucleus
there's a bowling ball in the center and
an electron b going around this grain of
sand that goes around the only thing
they have to do is draw their model of
the atom we can go with a hydrogen atom
we don't have to have iron or copper or
anything anything more complicated just
draw for me the hydrogen atom
and then explain why
okay
the electron bead doesn't fall
to the center where the nucleus is
or why it doesn't spontaneously fly away
if you cannot explain that
you do not have an atom
and your explanation of electricity the
flow of electron beads from atom the
atom is bunk
okay
and so what derrick miller did is the
same thing as alpha phoenix did is the
same thing that everybody else does out
there
and they're using the wrong atom they're
using an atom they cannot justify it's
an irrational atom because they don't
know why that little bead goes around
any more than anyone can explain to you
why pluto goes around the sun
okay what's keeping pluto bound to the
sun that's what you got to explain why
doesn't pluto fly away from the uh solar
system spontaneously
and if you say that there is nothing
connecting physically connecting pluto
with the sun simply because you can't
see it or touch it
then you put a spirit in that same
region you're doing
your
theory with black magic you're seeing
nothing is in contact between pluto and
the sun
but pluto doesn't fly away
that's what you're saying
and what you're saying essentially
whatever theory you have i don't care
because whatever theory you have you're
putting uh you're using black magic
you're saying it's done without a
mediator without a physical object
mediating pluto with a sun that's what
you're saying
okay and that is irrational science
okay
science
big word there just irrational that's an
irrational theory
you have to have a rational theory in
order to have a rational theory you need
a mechanism in order to have a mechanism
you have to mediate it you have to
simulate it with a physical object
the fact that you can't see or touch it
does not make it a
does not
reduce say that there's no object there
there is an object there we just can't
see or touch it because an object is
that which has shape not that which you
can see or touch
okay so how do we answer this gentleman
here well
we answer this way uh don't just follow
the herd of buffalo to the edge of the
cliff i mean the guy says this is what
most people right believe is physics
yeah i don't know about most people we
don't care about most people you don't
follow the herd of buffalo to the edge
of the cliff try to get a brain of your
own
don't use borrowed brains especially
that of the uh you know the scarecrow
there
uh when he went to oz he left his
old brain there and he got a new one i
guess right that's what the whiz gave
him
so uh you don't want to use his brain
now and you know maybe they sell you his
brain
at a discount or something don't don't
take it okay you'll have a tough time
though independently thinking brains are
scarce okay so you'll have to shop
around meanwhile remember that science
is not equal to democracy authority or
tradition
okay so this notion that this fellow has
that oh the majority of people believe
that physics is blah blah blah blah blah
we don't care what the majority of
people think
hey we don't we don't go by the majority
we this is not democracy we all vote
it doesn't work that way not in science
in science you got to rationalize it you
got to defend your definition
and so you
he didn't put a definition for physics
but he he suggests that the notion of
physics is
uh what the this guy did which is
criticize
uh derek muller
first of all criticism is not science
explanation is science that's the first
one and the second one is that this guy
proposed the same thing as derek muller
which is the planetary model and that
electricity consists of the flow of
beads
electron beads
okay so
knowing
this spa has said nothing new
okay here we have something new
something different but this fella he's
got the same thing as everybody else
okay another fellow talking about being
parrots here right
you know just mimicking what the uh
authorities and the
superiors told them says electrical
energy is one of about 25 types of
energy okay form of energy that results
from the flow of what charged particles
what are those particles the electron
beads right
and their charge means they have 1.6
times 10 to the minus 19 coulombs
each right
a quantity it carries the electron
carries with it energy is defined as a
catch-all what capacity
capacity to do work so what is energy
it's capacity whatever that is okay
there's no physical standalone object
called capacity as far as i know okay
but if you find one please draw it bring
it to the conference okay
a battery is a form of stored electrical
potential energy i'm going to be looking
at the battery today so uh it's a good
introduction to the subject uh it has
potential energy
potential capacity
what does that mean
potential capacity okay charge is
charged like in charged particles is a
property of matter okay so there is no
physical object called charge you can't
say you're going to move the charge
right
because he's saying it's a property it's
like saying i'm going to move the color
red
of the
you know the sweater sweater is red
or it's big you can't move big you can't
move
red you gotta move the sweater right so
we have to distinguish the property of
the sweater from the sweater okay
let's make sure we understand that okay
just uh like mass volume or density it
is measurable
yeah measurable yes like saying i can
measure color by you know maybe
in the case of red you can have 610
nanometer wavelength okay so you
measured it 610 nanometers right and
we measure so uh
but he said it's the flow of charged
particles
and other people just
say it's a flow of charges
okay
uh a charged battery has higher mass
than it does discharge when placed on on
scales
uh-huh so
what did it why does it weigh
differently that's what you gotta
explain
so the to say that a charged battery
weighs more
what are you saying it's a soul it's
spirit ways
something when you know you can pull
that spirit out and say here's the
charge here's the spirit
see these people go back and forth
between treating charge as a
mathematical concept and as a standalone
physical object and they get confused
they equate them
duality right and they get away within
they don't even realize it yeah they're
not smart enough to figure this stuff
out
okay so uh let's kill that parrot there
who all they do is just parrot the uh
official
words out there whatever they learn at
the monastery let's kill the parrot
okay if a battery weighs more when it is
charged does it that make charge a
physical object
if charge is a property of matter like
color or size does that make charge a
physical object
if electrical energy results from the
flow of charged so-called particles does
that make charge a physical object
and if energy is the capacity and a
battery stores this capacity right is
energy a physical object i mean what are
you storing
i mean it's not like storing uh beer in
your fridge right
can you see your touch capacity
and if you can't see your touch capacity
hopefully you don't define an object as
that which you can see or touch because
then um
you know you would not be able to touch
energy or call it a physical object
right which is the way he treated it
here
okay so uh
yeah all these people they do is just
parrot
they just copy and paste stuff they they
don't even analyze the stuff that they
copy and paste
they just say this is what i learned at
the monastery this is the catechism i
had to memorize okay
you know counting beads on the uh rosary
where people
they should try to get their money back
from where that wherever they studied
because they gypped them they gave them
a piece of paper worthless piece of
paper they said you're a phd
oh yeah so
great
but he got one ryan he says fields are
mathematical representation of
interactions absolutely it's a
mathematical representation that's all
that a field is okay
and here we look it up just in case okay
to make sure that everybody understands
this okay
what is a field a quantity okay this uh
this comes out of the wikipedia all of
this
represented by a number
that has a value for each point
in
space and time
okay so what is a number well a number
is a mathematical object they say okay
used to count measure and label okay
great
what is a value well value is any
definite
mathematical object again all these
mathematical objects right most often a
number
point an exact location in the space and
has no length with or height so yeah
hopefully a location has no length with
or height right
space and time what is space and time
any mathematical model which faces
fuses the three dimensions of space and
the one of dimension of time okay and
then just in case we look at space and
time separately space is the fundamental
space
i like that definition etc etc okay i
stopped there because it wasn't there
wasn't any point continuing if space is
the fundamental space right
and time when it's time the continued
sequence of existence and events that
occurs in irreversible succession from
the past through the present into the
future
so you wonder how they can bend time or
wipe time if this is the definition of
time
okay all right what are you warping
you're warping what continued sequence
of existence is that what you're warping
okay and so you see what a field is down
at the bottom which is what this file
said it's just a representation
mathematical representation that's how
it is a bunch of numbers
and the only condition that you have to
keep in mind is that numbers get away
get smaller
the farther away they are from ground
zero so if you have uh
gravity right it gets weaker
uh the farther away you get from like
the center of the earth or from whatever
object you're talking about
um
if you're talking about magnetism same
thing it gets weaker the farther away
you get okay so a field is what a bunch
of numbers values in space
what do you mean by space means that all
these numbers are floating in space of
course you're not supposed to imagine it
like that because it's a mathematical
concept nothing but that's what a field
is and a lot of these people don't
understand that
the word field was created by mr faraday
in the 1830s and he called the field
like magnetic field because he said you
know there's these lines there that have
an effect on visible matter he couldn't
see the field right and so he said well
i'm going to call this a magnetic field
and so people now say oh a magnetic
field what is that well if you put a
little charge in that
uh field region right
the field has different strengths at
different locations
and so the field became a series of
numbers
that describe each location that
comprises the so-called field
okay and that's what a field is there is
no physical standalone object called
field
the so-called field is is under the rope
model is very simple it's the threads
that are sweeping around in that region
now you have a physical object they're
threads
and you can't see or touch them okay
but we're not talking about values
mathematics just talks about the value
that a charge would have in other words
what acceleration what force etc what
energy you impart on a charged particle
that is found within the field
that's how the field is interpreted in
other words it's a mathematical concept
it's a mathematical concept made of many
mathematical numbers which is just a
value for each point in space
and you can't turn that into an object
and say oh the field is a physical
object no the object are the threads
that are sweeping around that form this
so-called field the region where a
particle is influenced
okay so
physics is about objects not about math
about numbers
okay uh
continuing here uh any thoughts on why
an electrical circuit has to be closed
and when this guy asked this question i
had no choice but to answer it and that
was the subject matter of today so this
is the question we're going to try to
answer okay why do we have to close that
circuit
okay
why can't we leave it open and have you
know all the electricity fly through the
air
very important question because you know
according to um
quantum mechanics
electricity they got rid of the atom
they don't even need the atom anymore
now it's just a flow of electrons
so all the electron b bees like you know
bullets
flow through space
and that's called uh electricity
so there should be no reason for the
electrons to jump the gap there
and reach the other side
okay
why not why don't they why don't they
just jump across
in space especially you have this
circuit in space there's nothing there
well
not in quantum
even the false vacuum is made of stuff
right but i mean in rational science you
got
empty space there we don't need to put
the word empty because space is that
which doesn't have shape
and so the question is will the
electrons jump across from one
point to the other across that
gap
okay and if not why do we have to close
it why do we have to close the circuit
make a closed circuit closed loop
circuit
okay
very important question right because uh
this is the one that leads us to an
understanding of electricity
okay um
here we have a dc circuit and we talked
about that the other day which is what
this file is saying uh you know if you
you close the circuit you have all these
electrons flowing
direct current right ac alternating
current a little different looks more
like this show this the other day
and it just goes back and forth
because you're changing the polarities
constantly okay somehow
and so the question is you know which
one is electricity does electricity have
to go all around or does electricity
just move back and forth
okay but the point here is that in ac at
least right
it's a
local
phenomena if you put a lamp there where
that resistor is on the
right side there
uh well then it's going to turn on okay
so the question is how does do those
electrons
produce this light this why does the
light turn on when those electrons are
moving back and forth
between atoms okay
okay
so let's uh move on here
this is what it looks like in a vacuum
chamber okay important to see this as
well okay
and there you see the atoms and
essentially this is the notion they have
uh electron beats is moving from atom to
atom from one
uh
plate to another from cathode to anode
okay
okay so this is their notion uh
we compared it against the
one that we propose in instead which is
this we're saying that uh actually
uh electricity is the
bunch of merged electron shells that are
spinning in situ okay
okay and so now we get to uh voltage and
find out why
that had to be connected okay
and we start with the definition of
voltage first we need to know what this
voltage is because it's voltage that
triggers
whether whether you use my version which
is the
merged electron shells that are spinning
in situ or you use the bead model where
the electron bead goes from atom to atom
you need to have this thingy
trigger it which is known as voltage and
what the hell is voltage okay
and it's got something to do with
positive and negative okay
and here you have uh
definition says voltage potential
difference or electric pressure is the
difference in uh
electric potential between two points
okay so it's some kind of pressures some
potential difference whatever that is
right now we don't know but this is the
definition okay so we have two points
and there's a difference in potential or
there's pressure from one point to the
other
okay pressure we all understand right
you push the box that's called pressure
pressure is push
okay
on the other hand um potential
difference well usually it's the
notion that we have of gravity like if
you're on the mountain and you jump
hopefully with a parachute or something
right
uh you fall downwards okay yeah why
because there's a potential difference
they call that a potential why we don't
know because again with the word
potential we're not identifying the
invisible object that's pulling on you
or pushing on you all we're doing is
saying there is a potential difference
that's just mathematics and that's just
a description
okay so let's distinguish that from
explanation which is what caused you to
fall downwards why did you fall to the
sky
okay that's that's the issue that we're
trying to resolve here it says voltage
is defined so that negatively charged
objects
are pulled towards higher voltages
while positively charged objects are
pulled towards lower voltages so we have
this potential difference okay
and so they're just
introducing this notion of positive and
negative
and you say well what does that mean in
in physical term what what is this
positive and negative and it turns out
that they never
they never defined it they have no idea
what positive and negative is
they could have said it's a and z
just like they say north and south right
they could have said east and west
i mean what is this positive negative
what does it mean from a physical
standpoint okay
and you know we always say well the
positive side of the magnet attracts the
negative side yeah
you could say a attracts b
red attracts blue you could have said
many things
what's the difference between positive
and negative okay that's what we need to
figure out
otherwise you know all you did was just
a description you you don't you still
don't understand how a magnet works
okay and so here we have um the notion
that they have a voltage okay
and it's this uh notion of water they
say this is a difference in potential so
they have the positive on the top
negative on the bottom could be the
other way around depending on what
particle your is it the positive
particle that's moving towards the other
side
okay so keep keep that in mind they have
no idea so this is arbitrary that you
can put a positive on the high one and
the negative on the low one it could be
the other way around okay in fact the
next uh
thing shows it here okay
uh is that what we're saying we're
saying that we have something uh that is
higher than the other is that why the
electron beads roll downwards
to the one on the bottom is that the
analogy let me show that again okay side
by side i mean what they're saying and
again i got don't worry about the signs
because again they say that the positive
could go to the
negative or vice versa so the signs are
really
unimportant in that sense in what i'm
showing here the important here is that
they're saying it's a difference in
potential that's what i'm showing here
so a difference in potential we can all
understand the analogy of the water
flowing downwards because it's gravity
whatever gravity is okay we don't we're
not concerned about that right now we're
just saying there's a difference in
potential because of gravity because
water tends to go down
so they use this as an analogy for
voltage are we saying that the electron
beads which is what is rolling in this
case right which is what's going from
one atom to another are we saying that
the electron beads are flowing downwards
because
one of the terminals is higher than the
other
can we
switch them around and find out if the
electron beads flow in the other
direction can we lift the
positive in this case in this example
higher than the
negative
and now the electron beads will flow in
the other direction
because if this is not the case then the
analogy the water analogy
is irrelevant
it has nothing to do with what
electricity is so the analogy is wrong
but this is the analogy 99 of the people
out there use to explain voltage they
say it's just a difference in potential
what do you mean a difference in
potential we understand the wider one
how does that work with electricity
are the electron beats rolling down an
inclined plane
that's the question okay
okay let's get rid of these
okay so you see where i'm going with all
this if this is
voltage
and it's a difference in potential
are the beads rolling downwards on an
inclined plane
well very easy we could just put one
terminal on the uh higher than the other
will the electron beats flow in the
opposite direction
i don't think so
okay so the analogy is worthless because
we haven't understood anything all we
understood is that the word potential
and potential is a mathematical term it
has nothing to do with physics
okay so
potential
no no go okay so here's the quantum
mechanics version of a battery a lead
battery i'm going to go with the
simplest of all i'm not going to cover
all the
possibilities the hundreds of
possibilities that there are for
generating current and voltage and so on
i'm going to look at this
which is the lead battery
lead acid battery um
which is the first battery that was
invented i think
and so the issue here is why why do
those
beads the electron beads go around you
can see the red ones there those are
supposedly the electron beads are going
around in the circuit okay what causes
them to go around okay and for that you
need to look at the chemistry of this
okay so let's move to the chemistry here
you have it okay you have the um
electron beads flowing but what's
happening what's triggering that well
you have the one
side one battery is lead and the other
one is lead dioxide okay
and uh what happens there's a chemical
reaction with the
sulfuric acid that's diluted sulfuric
acid okay that's that bath there
and there you have the chemical
reactions okay and you create these uh
these uh hydrogen uh
ions okay
and what happens is that they say when
that when those chemical reactions take
place the beads move around
the electron beads move around from one
terminal to the other
okay so you need that chemical reaction
and you can see it's a closed system the
question is whether that reaction would
stay in place would remain
if
you break that circuit
okay
and the issue here is that you have to
be aware of is the following that
there's a reaction between the sulfuric
acid there and the lead
okay but there's a chemical
reaction that you can have it's just if
you just pour sulfuric acid on lead
there will be a certain
reaction there but that doesn't cause
electricity per se
in order for you to have electricity you
need to connect that wire okay around
the green wire all around and there has
to be a closed system because now the
electron beads flow and they stimulate
the reaction between the sulfuric acid
and the lead terminals
okay so that's what you have to keep in
mind okay the reaction is stimulated by
the electricity
otherwise you would not have that flow
of uh
in other words it's a
it speeds up the reaction that's the
point otherwise you would have just a
chemical reaction between the acid and
one lead terminal which is very slow
process okay
the electricity is what speeds it all up
okay and
so
one thing you have to keep in mind is
that that is really a
what you're seeing there the electron
beams moving straight forward that's not
really how it's done but that's how it's
always illustrated let's illustrate a
little more like it is okay and here it
is
they they jiggle around they kind of
spiral around the electron beads are
known to spiral around the wire as they
move so this this notion here that you
see here this one is wrong okay it's not
straightforward from adam to adam for
some reason okay for some reason they do
this they move around like oscillating
they they spiral around the wire okay
and this is very important to understand
that okay
and it's already been um
you know shown
through
many observations many experiments in
the past uh that this is the case that
these things go around it's like a fact
so we don't need to i mean if you have
doubts about it go to lab and do your
experiment convince yourself of it uh
this is something that is already well
known it's a fact
uh it's like saying that the earth is
round and you're saying no the earth is
flat yeah if you want to
buck the trend and say it's flat fine
you're a flat earth or great now the
earth is round it's spherical okay
and that's why gravity works otherwise
gravity wouldn't work and likewise this
is the fact that the electron spiral
around has already been shown you know
ad nauseum and here you
see as soon as
fleming's rule really
but here you see ac going back and forth
okay and the question is this um this ac
it doesn't flow all the way it's like
it's
not only spiraling okay so these two
things have to be put together not only
are the electrons spiraling but they're
not moving all the way to the terminal
they're they're what uh what was his
name um
uh derrick muller
suggested
the and which which is shown by the ac
that the electron doesn't move very much
it moves it drifts very little they said
it's the field that moves at the speed
of light
it's the signal that moves but the
electron moves very little they say okay
so let's see the electron moves very
little and it's spiraling
so more or less it's spiraling in situ
and you have tons of these electrons
spiraling in situ okay
so keep that in mind this is what we're
seeing here and again this comes from uh
what is known as fleming's rule okay
here you see it
this fellow his name was john fleming
okay he was a
electrician he worked for marconi
beginning of the
20th century
and he came up with the left-hand rule
which is what you see there force
goes perpendicular to magnetic field
which is perpendicular to current
all three are perpendicular to each
other and there you see it with the
light
the electro magnetic wave okay you have
the electric field one direction
magnetic field 90 degrees to it okay and
where's the force or where's the energy
which direction is light traveling
perpendicular to both
okay we got that
okay so here we have uh
fleming's rule applied to electrons and
you can see they're spiraling around
if uh if you find an electron in an
electric in a
magnetic field okay
what you'll see is that it'll spiral
around okay because it's moving in one
direction while it's going up in circles
and so what that does is compel the
just think of that trajectory okay
it's not only not only um
going around but going around forward
which is a spiral path
in fact that's what the
people at the
large hadron collider say they
accelerate electrons they accelerate
protons
they don't say that the electron moves
back and forth
they say no we accelerate all around the
beam line
what do you mean i thought uh
that was just moving a little bit what
you're accelerating is what the field
the signal
the abstract numbers
and these people say no we accelerate
the electron beads
or the
ions the uh you know they strip the
allegedly they strip the electron from a
hydrogen atom they're accelerating the
protons
they don't say that the proton moves
back and forth they say they accelerate
it all around the beam line okay
and uh here you have the helix okay
another version of that same one it's
it's a helix going inside a wire okay
that's what it is it's a helical motion
it's a spiraling type of motion
okay so that's how an electron moves
along a wire
okay but then again does it move all the
way or does it move just a little bit
okay
how does it move does it move a little
bit
or does it move in in other words does
it move in situ essentially and
in circles meaning if it moved a little
bit forward in circle it described a
helix a spiral
right
keep that in mind that's the motion
so what are these uh
uh people showing well they're showing
something like this they're saying in a
magnetic field the force is always at
right angles to the motion of the
electron fleming's left hand rule and so
and and so the resulting path of the
electron is circular
and if it's moving forward it's a spiral
okay
what are all these people describing
well it seems like they're describing a
rope turning in place or or what i call
the serpentine you know merge cells
right that's what it would appear
okay let's find out
here we have the dynamic version of that
okay just so you can see it okay so in
the magnetic field the electron would
behave like that it's kind of spiraling
and if the electron is moving in the
direction in some direction right for
example in the direction of the arrows
there well then uh yeah it's gonna it's
gonna move like a spiral it's going to
be a spiraling motion
okay
okay so what are these people describing
what do we what can we conclude from
this
well here it is these are the
conclusions
let you get that how did it become so
big
give me a second here
okay
let's get it up here
okay so what have we been this have
these folks been describing all these
years well the electron bead spirals
okay
it spirals uh more or less in situ okay
it doesn't move very far they say the
electron beam moves very little like
from one atom to the next in a spiraling
manner
right because it's got a return if it's
going to do alternate current
it doesn't go all the way what travels
all the way with travels at the speed of
light is the field the signal okay we
covered that the other day
it doesn't travel all the way to the
terminal and it spirals for no reason
they have no mechanism for why that
electron beat spirals or even moves
outside the atom to begin with except
the so-called voltage thingy which we
still don't know what it is it's just a
potential difference you know between
something high and something low some
kind of pressure
of what or who knows what because we
don't have the what
it just says it's pressure whatever that
is right whatever's causing it
it is surrounded by
lines of force okay remember when the
electron moves
it moves in a magnetic field what is a
field a bunch of lines of force that's
what a field is a magnetic field right
okay known collectively as a magnetic
field what is the rope model uh merge
electron shell swinging threads around
okay so we have
the all these merge shells okay their
electrons are made of the same threads
as the rope that interconnects them we
have two
atoms
okay to make it simple two atoms which
are merged one with the other like i
showed the other day in the case of
hydrogen
gas h2
that's just two atoms two merged atoms a
figure eight atom uh molecule
and all these are turning around
when they do they swing around the
threads
okay some of the threads that
either that make up the rope between
them or the ones that make up their own
bodies some of those threads start
swinging around okay
and
so what is this uh positive negative
it's clockwise counterclock clockwise
rotation from one point of view you see
it is clockwise
and if i do this well for you hopefully
this is counterclockwise right
right for me it's uh
from from my vantage point right okay
i'm i'm seeing that my hand is moving
clockwise but from your point of view
hopefully it's uh going counterclockwise
okay
and that's what's happening uh it's just
clockwise counterclockwise rotation
of the uh the whole um
serpentine as i call it merge elec rows
extensive rows of electron shells merge
electron shells and so a circuit must be
closed for the entire serpentine to
troll on itself and stimulate the
chemical reaction between uh the
sulfuric acid and the either the
lead or the lead dioxide turns it into
lead um what is that uh
sulfite sulfate
uh so so the issue here is the following
that you need that chemical reaction
because
um
if you just pour acid you know sulfuric
acid you pour it on lead there's going
to be a chemical reaction there it's a
slow
it's like almost if you pour water
on an iron will there be a reaction well
yeah you can have oxidation
over time rust right it takes a long
time but if you stimulate it with
electricity that reaction is much faster
and that's what's happening what you
have is the serpentine is twirling all
around the circuit by doing so it comes
back to the other terminal and now what
it's doing is uh stimulating the
reaction now the reaction is faster
which
you know stimulates the twirling of the
uh
of the entire uh serpentine that goes
around and so uh
by going around and twirling fast it's a
self-sustaining system okay until you
open the circuit
okay so that's the notion we we want to
give you there
okay and here is we're going to
illustrate that okay here's uh the the
reaction
uh here's the bath and you have the
sulfuric in contact with the lead and
the lead dioxide and it's relatively
slow that's what i'm trying to
illustrate there it's a relatively slow
process okay
but what happens uh when you put the
circuit in there when you connect the
terminals well now what you have is you
know it moves a lot faster okay
moves faster and what it does is uh
trigger the reaction to occur faster and
that's why we have electricity now the
the serpentine that goes or serpentines
there's many of them going around they
move a lot faster
electricity does stimulate the reaction
which in turn stimulates the electricity
moving around okay
and again i'm doing this with the lead
battery okay i want to make sure that
you understand that this is just for the
lead battery
there are other
scenarios and people go say bill you
didn't explain this you didn't explain
that yeah right now i just want people
to understand the basics how it
how it works with the lead battery okay
very simple
you have a reaction between sulfuric
and the metal
and
if if you just have
that reaction and nothing else nope
you've got you know you got a very slow
process and there is no electricity
there if you want electricity you got to
connect the terminal to the other side
right through a wire and it that
whole thing is now connected
uh you know around the wire and the
serpentine now is what triggers the
whole reaction to occur
okay so you need a closed circuit
because of that
okay
okay uh let's get on to the
uh questions and comments people made
since last time a lot of them have to do
again with what is an object
and here you have it says your physical
rope objects are made of wet physical
substance
i could say truthfully that wind is not
a substance or object good good wind is
not a physical wind is a concept you're
right there it was air moving at high
speed that
wrecked my house yeah correct good it's
air is the physical object known as a
gas okay
and the objects are really the little
oxygen atoms
or you can say even the molecules fine
but we look at that whole thing okay we
call air that gas
and we take it as a single body
so we say it's it's air that pushed my
house down we can say that air is the
object because we're looking at the
shape of that whole blob of air we're
not saying oh what is it made out of now
we don't care about that we're saying
we're looking air as a as a whole okay
and it was there that wrecked this house
if there is no wind hence no force
okay
to feel uh
or measure must we say air therefore
does not exist
okay so the guy is confusing a million
things here okay uh he's confusing
object with exist okay
and we've had that in the past
here let me show you uh where is it
human can't made that uh mistake okay
here they are okay they say uh hume said
the idea of existence then is the very
same with the idea of what we conceived
to be existent okay
that idea when conjoined with the idea
of any object makes no addition to it
whatever we conceive we conceive to be
existent and a few years later kent said
about the same thing he said by whatever
and by however many predicates i may
think of a thing
even in completely determining it
nothing is really added to it if i add
that the thing exists
okay and so yeah this file first of all
confuses uh thing
object with exist okay that's the first
problem okay he thinks they're synonyms
and that's why he talks about
uh air existing you know the the issue
of uh existence should not even the word
should not even enter the discussion
we're talking about what a thing is okay
that's the first one wind is not a thing
he said it right at first now i don't
know why he says
if there is no force to push the wind i
guess
well what is this force that's pushing
the wind
please draw it
show me what force is pushing the wind
or compelling the wind to blow down your
house
okay
so uh but what is the issue he says what
are your physical roasts made of and for
this we have to go you know here
and to let's put over here uh it's known
as uh the word idiot okay
and a rational individual that just has
ideas well in idiot right
we put the ot making it a big idea right
and so an individual big idea is known
as an idiot okay
and these are typical idiotic statements
that people make okay
the first one is what is the
electromagnetic rope made of those are
the type of questions they ask what do
you mean by shape
why is there something rather than
nothing
it is unscientific to ask what came
before the big bang
you're not supposed to take the uh warp
space-time canvas analogy literally yeah
sure
so how come the earth uh doesn't fly out
of the solar system right
it's like asking what's north of the
north pole these are type of answers uh
some of these idiots give you okay
and a quantum particle can be at two
places at once and so on and so forth
these are the type of
issues that these people always uh raise
questions and comments that they make
and so this uh person is asking what is
uh rope made out of why is this an
idiotic uh question okay uh here let's
find out okay
asking what is a rope made of is why is
it
irrational uh mariology is unscientific
what is mereology well look it up and
then you'll educate yourself
uh object uh it's not equal what it is
made out of uh object is that which has
shape so you cannot ask what is it made
out of okay
then it turns out that you know
an object
in this case the thread right
is a
an elementary or fundamental entity
they're at the bottom okay so it's
irrational to ask what is an elementary
fundamental entity made out of and for
that you need to look at what an
elementary entity is okay so look at
elementary ethidine you'll find out what
it is and why it's an irrational
question okay to ask what is an
elementary entity made of okay
table is not four legs and a board table
is a single piece body you point to okay
so you cannot say oh a table is four
legs and a board
you can't say that
okay
table is what you point it to and named
and so physics outlaws anything uh which
is mariology which is ether field plasma
vortex dark matter false vacuum all that
kind of stuff that's that's all
irrational because the person who's
proposing this is referring to what the
thing is made out of because that's what
he's going to use
he's not going to use the fields he's
going to use what's inside the field
what affected
the charged particle inside the field
for example or what affected the ether
inside the ether they say well the
shaking of the ether is what is
light for example the wave of light
that's the waving of the ether what is a
plasma well again it's uh
something that happens inside the plasma
it's the motion of an electron inside
the atom the
atom the atom spits out an electron
essentially you know or gains an
electron that's what a plasma is so
there's motion inside this static
object because they're referring to what
plasma is doing about its constituents
and not about the plasma itself okay
same with vortex what is vortex well you
know tornado is a vortex and you say
well
uh is the
tornado a single piece object and now
they're referring to the air that's
moving around so don't talk about the
tornado talk about the air that's the
object okay and even with air you can
talk about what the air is made out of
that air is good for
as an object to talk about tornado but
tornado is not an object tornado is a
concept it's toward its swirling air
that's what it is and so on what is dark
matter uh well dark matter matters all
these little particles that make up dark
matter and so on so all these are
referring to what the thing is made of
okay and that's irrational in science
okay
and the electromagnetic rope is made of
two threads
okay that's what it's made of so i don't
know why he had a why he asked this
question you know what is the rope made
of don't you know i mean
people should just visit the local
hardware store
and uh and that's for rope you know and
they'll give you something like this
okay
ask them for a two strand rope that's
what i use okay and there are ropes that
are made of more strands but ask them
for a two-strand rope see what they give
you and you'll find out what it's made
of it's made out of two strands
how can that be so difficult why did you
have to ask that question okay
yeah okay and here all related to to
objects right so if you reject see touch
draw and imagine shape doesn't mean
anything at all like
my poor god my poor my poor devil
how do you point to an invisible
intangible object without imagining and
drawing it you know a simple simply
impossible
the magic rope isn't an invisible
intangible object but a dynamic concept
rope is a concept
between any two atoms uh that's why you
know i put that the definition of the
word object destroys all religion these
people are upset
because they have no definition to
propose an exchange they come up with
all these irrational questions
i wonder what's going through their
minds
poor people you know i mean
and
you know me i'm i'm the culprit i i do
plead guilty you know i
i put this uh
these issues there and it destroys their
religion they say look i studied 10
years i got a phd
and now you're telling me that
everything i learned at the monastery
was wrong
yeah so they they object they don't like
these definitions because it destroys
what they believe in and so they're
going to find them and they realize this
and so they're going to fight it with
everything they've got
okay if i raises an issue about weight
says i disagree with weight being static
okay
weight is a concept because we can't
point to a point at weight and it
describes the effect of two objects
pressing against each other aha it does
is that what a weight is uh objects
pressing against each other
uh
weight is not a pull of gravity
because that's what everybody describes
out there now this is saying it's
pushing
an object pushing on a scale i guess
he's referring to right for example an
asteroid in space
can't
be said to weigh anything but when it
impacts the earth's surface then it has
weight and even when moving towards
earth it only has velocity and no weight
in my opinion
no no no no no poor fellow poor fellow
he is just so mis disoriented he doesn't
even know he doesn't even have his feet
on the ground he doesn't have any idea
weight is static by definition
okay let me repeat that wait a static
concept by definition okay weight is
equal to
g big g okay
gravitational constant g mass mass
divided by distance squared
what is the distance separating the two
masses it's a static concept by
definition
okay
that's the first thing you have to
understand second you're wrong
the the
astronaut falling through space he
weighs differently at every location
without putting him on a scale okay
because of the equation and here's the
equation let's put it up there so we can
talk a little more
illustratively okay let's illustrate
this okay there we have the astronaut
okay he weighs differently at different
locations without putting him on the
scale you do not have to weigh the guy
you do not have to push him against the
wall
to say oh he's got weight
he has weight already the fact that he
doesn't feel the weight is irrelevant
the equation tells us that he has weight
okay what's the equation it's newton's
ascribed to
newton which is uh
again force in other words weight equal
gravitational constant
mass mass divided by distance squared
okay so
by definition weight is static okay so
that you believe or you don't agree it's
got nothing to do with that at all you
have to accept it whether you like it or
not that's the point and this person
doesn't understand that it's like saying
you know black is black and he says no
no i don't know if i'm going to believe
that you know
yeah black is black i'm sorry
if if it's black we call it black and
you have to accept that that color is
called black and red is another color
and you point to and say that's going to
be my standard for red okay and so it's
by definition we call that red let's
assume 600 uh nanometers right we say
that's the perfect red
anything
uh beyond is the light red or anything
in front is gonna be dark red but that's
red okay
and by definition it's red now you can't
say well i don't know if i believe that
it's red by definition okay so
i don't know what to tell you
okay move on another follow here says
assuming a rope hypothesis if every atom
is connected to every other atom would
it be rational to assume that all
potentially empty space is
occupied by the ropes
thus there is no such thing as empty
space
i don't know how this can be so
difficult
please people give me a break
okay uh there's a rope okay illustrated
okay
what's the black stuff that serves as
backdrop to the rope and ensures that
this object is not an infinite block
because if you don't have uh matter
chiseled
by space so to speak
contoured by space surrounded by space
then that object would be a single
infinite block of whatever
hopefully even god
almighty god is surrounded by space
is contoured by space
space serves as his backdrop because if
that space wasn't there poor god would
be an infinite block of whatever
if you can imagine that okay so no
something has to give shape to things
and all objects are made of space and
shape
okay all objects we don't have to
specify the uh word um space because we
say shape and you cannot even
conceptualize space shape
without space with a ultimately right
in the ultimate case
every object is surrounded by space
every atom is contoured is encapsulated
if if you want to use those terms by
space what is space that which has no
shape
how can this be so difficult
is it i mean is it so difficult
my son says it is difficult and i
i have trouble believing that i have
trouble accepting that i'm sorry
for me this is just
the second nature okay a fellow says
what is an atom i say it is a magnet
yeah in a way uh it is a magnet okay but
then we have to figure out what a magnet
is right
uh an atom is uh under the rope model is
a membrane uh the electron membrane that
encapsulates
a um
uh proton i call it the dandelion
because that's what it looks like
all the
like an urchin sea urchin rolled up sea
urchin all these spikes pointing
outwards radially okay and so we have
the electron membrane
encapsulating the proton star okay
and so there you see it that's a cross
section of it and what you see is uh all
those ropes
uh when the atom vibrates back and forth
it torques those ropes and that's what
we call light
and the
aggregate all that light is we call
energy right that's the energy and uh
charge is what's happening at the edge
at the surface of the electron
shell or electron membrane what you have
is there you could say a rubbing
some
unimaginable friction
when the rope uh
when the rope is released and absorbed
which is the
um when an atom releases energy and
absorbs energy under the
bohr model right so that
releasing and absorbing energy is what
you see there it's releasing and
absorbing
rope
okay when it does so okay it torques the
rope
and when it does so all that friction
going on around the electron membrane
that's what we call charge that's the
charge on the electron which we measured
as 1.6 times 10 to the minus 19 coulombs
okay so that's the notion but then the
question is if that's the atom uh how
does it become a magnet
you know and a magnet so you have to
imagine these two bar magnets being
attracted and there are fields forming a
single field like you see there
but that's subject matter for wednesday
so